Republican Congressman clay Higgins who
describes himself as being for Law and
Order appears to have committed criminal
battery on video attacking an activist
take a look at this mediaite reports
house Republican manhandles protester
who tells him get off me you're hurting
me clay Higgins physically removed a
protester from a press conference with
Paul gozar and Lauren bobert on
Wednesday as the man screamed get off me
you're hurting me
several recordings showed Democratic
Socialist protester Jake Burdette being
pushed by Higgins out of the DC event as
the congressman said you're out we have
the video
lawyers have reviewed this and have said
to me they believe this is Criminal
battery take a look
up you're out
you're out
aren't you a congress person
you're a U.S congressman
[Music]
so for people just listening what we
have seen and are still watching here is
Congressman clay Higgins a radical
lunatic Republican grabbing this
individual uh forcing him uh out and
Away in the sort of bear hug shove and I
mean listen if you if you're really
about Law and Order that's a crime it's
battery and it's criminal when it's done
with the intent to harm okay unclear
injure not really clear annoy absolutely
or offend another person without their
consent Jake Burdette clearly did not
consent to being manhandled in that way
when we talk about criminal battery it
doesn't matter if it's light or it's
severe in terms of the contact if it's
unlawful and offensive and meets those
requirements then it is indeed criminal
battery if you spit on someone
after an argument or something like that
um even if they're not injured if they
did not consent to that then it's a form
of criminal battery and it's usually a
misdemeanor punishable by up to six
months in jail or a fine states have
different degrees and classifications of
battery you can have aggravated battery
sexual battery Family Violence battery
Etc but if you are for Law and Order you
can only see that and say that was a
crime committed by the Republican clay
Higgins now mehdi Hassan had a good
tweet about this where he said
if a democratic member of Congress if a
squad member did this to a conservative
protester it would be 24 7 on Fox news
for days and that's absolutely right
imagine for a second okay just imagine
for a second if AOC had done this to
some conservative protester imagine that
it was a female protester right two two
women it would be 24 7 on Fox News so
I'm not confident that clay Higgins is
going to be held accountable for that
but certainly not indicative of Law and
Order that's for damn sure plastic it's
everywhere we look and not enough is
being done about it 100 billion plastic
bags are used and thrown away every year
here's something super simple you can do
to reduce plastic and help the planet a
little bit our sponsor hold on bags is
the company making plastic free trash
bags and zip seal kitchen bags they're
just as strong and high quality as the
plastic bags you're used to hold on bags
are 100 percent plant-based and home
compostable meaning they break down in
just weeks not decades their zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
size to fit all of your needs whether
it's carrots or crayons at home I put
all of my food waste in a hold on trash
bag throw it in the compost pile and
when I throw a hold on trash bag in my
dumpster I love knowing it's not filling
our landfills and oceans with plastic
single use Plastics harm the planet at
every Stage production disposal
decomposition join the growing movement
away from single-use plastic these
products are really great it's so easy
to make the switch go to hold on
bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below